I don't know Mance if you know but I
know the two big stunts in the next one
and part two oh yes if you have any
intel
hello everybody and welcome to another
episode of the after show this isn't
just another episode though you have a
mission should you choose to accept it
and that is
to sit through the whole thing and watch
me and my favorite guest ever Scott
movie Mance talk about my favorite movie
of the year I just gave away a spoiler
dead reckoning Mission Impossible dead
reckoning part one I should warn you if
you do choose to accept this mission
that this is a spoiler-filled episode so
if you have not seen Mission Impossible
dead reckoning part one do yourselves a
favor go see it and then come back and
join the discussion unless you'd love to
have everything spoiled for you so
without further Ado welcome to man The
Myth the legend not Tom Cruise Scott
movie Mance you are the man the myth and
the Legends when I got the email saying
we would love for you to be a part of
the mission impossible dead reckoning
spoiler-filled after show review I was
like best email ever I love this movie I
think just as much as you do I love Tom
Cruise maybe almost as much as you do
did you just admit that you like him
almost as much as me I thought you were
gonna say more than you well maybe more
it depends because I just was and I love
Maverick top gun Maverick I thought last
year just like Steven Spielberg said to
Tom Cruise at the Oscar nominees
luncheon he saved Hollywood's butt that
movie is fantastic and he's following up
top gun Maverick a Paramount film with
another great Paramount action film well
score is a very fresh 96 I don't know if
there's ever been a fresher tomato and
the audience score is 94 the critics
consensus is with World threatening
stakes and epic set pieces to match that
massive title Mission Impossible dead
reckoning part one proves this is still
a franchise you should choose to accept
well I give that a 100 that I agree
because this movie which had a very long
production this movie was in production
for three years it started production in
February of 2020 and it shot all through
the very very the most difficult part of
the pandemic when everyone was in
lockdown and this movie kept going and
the fact that this movie is as strong as
it is it's a great movie anyway it's I
think you know not to skip ahead too far
but best Mission yet wow it is the best
Mission yet but when you look at the how
they had to film this movie onto the
most difficult cult circumstances
unprecedented circumstances at a time
when the future of movie going was
really in question and they finished it
and and it was so worth the wait because
the movie is phenomenal so let me ask
you a question because you just said and
we're going to get to our rankings of
how much we like these films uh the
order there's this is the seventh
Mission Impossible movie I'm just
curious when you say it is the best
Mission Impossible because a lot of
people believe that Fallout couldn't be
topped some people like others but I
think the consensus is that Fallout is
the best Mission Impossible movie this
one has just come out so I haven't
really heard a lot of people give their
new ranking but why do you think it's
the best one okay first of all you're
right I agree with you a lot of people
feel like Fallout is the best one before
dead reckoning and maybe even after dead
reckoning and Fallout is great came out
in 2018 and it's still to this day the
highest grossing Mission Impossible
movie with 791 million dollars worldwide
look you've spent those facts mans it is
great it is a great movie but the reason
I love Dev Reckoning part one of my
reason is because of the villain okay
the villain here Nikki is not just a
person the villain here perfect timing
for this movie to drop when it is
dropping is AI The Entity artificial
intelligence now keep in mind the movie
was in production for three years but
screenwriter Chris Macquarie had been
working on for years before that yeah so
to work on the screenplay years and
years ago then to film the movie and
have it drop when the both the writers
and the actors are striking over many
things including and especially because
of artificial intelligence you're
watching this movie you just go oh my
gosh she's pathetic it is totally
prophetic but also it's a smart film The
plotting because it is from an Academy
Award winner Christopher Macquarie won
an Oscar for writing the usual suspects
he is an amazing screenwriter and all of
the Mission Impossible movies that he
wrote Rogue nation and Fallout and now
Dev Reckoning are really smart but then
of course there is the action and you
know all the the most publicized scene
of him doing the motorcycle jump and
then the base jump that's a great great
stunt a great scene but it's not even
the best scene of the movie and if
you've seen the film as you have you
know that the last 30 minutes are off
the hook the last 30 minutes are off the
hook in terms of okay but let me okay so
if you hadn't seen the motorcycle jump
prior to seeing the film because that
was the thing that they released a
featurette right they showed us the
behind the scenes if it was a surprise
because we knew the train sequence was
coming but we hadn't seen most of it
right we'd seen a shot or two in the
trailers featurettes if you hadn't seen
the motorcycle jump
would you still think that yes I would
and here's why because the motorcycle
job it's like he rides the bike up he
takes off he lets go with the bike he
does the the base jump and then Lance
and then it's over
but the train until he lands sideways
through the glass which is great you
know there's the humor in the movie too
right yeah yeah but the reason why the
train sequence near the end is so great
is because it goes on for like 30
minutes you know there's the fight
between Eastside Morales and Tom Cruise
at the top of the train and then there's
where they have to unlock the engine so
that keeps going to save the rest of the
train which it almost does and then the
way each car kind of falls off the
suspense right the suspense keeps going
you really felt like Ethan Hunt and
Haley Atwell who plays his you know
partner that they were really in danger
it's not like oh he's going to be okay
like you felt the danger and that's what
makes that the better stun and you feel
like
you're that person there looking down
and seeing the abyss and hanging where
the motorcycle it's not the POV isn't
the same you're watching objectively
exactly and so you don't feel like oh
like if they had had they should have
put a freaking GoPro on the man and then
watch him go like seriously that's what
I want to see that actually I want to
see the GoPro of Tom because somebody
said to me and it's just so Preposterous
somebody said to me like well how far
was the fall like what a few thousand
feet I'm like because you would have
survived that was still alive like it's
not like he was jumping out of a plane
I'm like it was more dangerous for that
reason that he was jumping on the plane
but go ahead you try that yeah yeah yeah
wait the velocity that he comes off that
thing and also also the sort of the
train like the way that it defies
gravity like like when the trains like
sort of tumbling in over and then
they're just kind of like like it's
they're in zero zero g for a moment the
zero g shot where everything lifts in
the air I'm towing and everything yeah I
asked McCory on the carpet I was like
how did you do it and of course he
wouldn't want he didn't want to tell me
it was like Inception like how did you
do that what did you do because it's so
seamless that whatever CG they use that
you're just like oh my gosh very little
it's something so much practice it's so
practical and that is what makes these
movies so great again the fact that you
have the seventh film since 1996 okay so
it's been almost 30 years and that they
are still topping themselves I know my
order is a little different than just
like you know everyone is better than
the one before right but not by much but
it does the stick pretty close and we'll
get to that in a moment yeah
um so let's I mean I agree with you
about the AI by the way because I was
gonna say that most villains see
whenever I watch Like a horror movie
what scares me more a mass murderer or a
ghost you know what scares me more the
ghost because I can't control that the
mass murderer I can strategize right I
can like get out of the house so ghost
stories have always scared me this is
why I love the villain too because the
the fact that it was AI
sometimes mustache twirling villains in
movies I'm like they're not scary or
they're not that menacing you're judging
the performance and you're judging how
scary a villain they are this was
something totally new right we haven't
seen something like this before and
you're right it was completely
sophisticated and it was the villain
that scared me most of all the mission
impossible films because I was like how
do you outsmart it how do you beat it
you almost can't right I think that the
villains in The Mission Impossible films
have been really really good do great
Scott from mi2 I thought he was a really
good villain philis Seymour Hoffman a
mission impossible free I know a lot of
people haven't seen the third movie came
out in 2006 directed by JJ Abrams his
first feature film as a director a lot
of people kind of forget about that well
I think they've been going for so long
right that it is I had to re-watch all
of the films because you remember which
one was that which one was the Burj
which one and I know you don't feel that
because you remember everything but I
don't sometimes a week after I watch a
movie I gotta go watch it again because
I forget everything that happens in it
the difference between the mission
impossible films and let's say The Fast
and Furious movies are so I think the
mission impossible films because you
basically up until Rogue Nation you've
had a different director for each film
and it feels like you've had a different
director for each movie each one is
totally different stylistically
different but then with Rogue nation and
Fallout and now they're Reckoning one
and hope two whenever that comes out and
Macquarie really really gets it he has a
great professional relationship with
with Tom Cruise he also did Jack Reacher
uh and he I think he wrote or co-wrote
uh Valkyrie from 2008 which underrated
movie excellent film but the villain
like you know Lang The Syndicate guy
from Rogue Nation really really good
villain but thank you get to like oh
wait a minute it's AI remember when I
saw mission for the first time wrote you
know dead reckoning which I've now seen
three times oh you have seen it three
times three times when I was at the
first press screen that I got to go to I
just went you've got to be kidding me
like holy moly like it felt like the
most plausible villain yes yes that's it
is it's plausible like somebody who's
that evil and I'm gonna destroy the
world isn't necessarily plausible but an
AI that turns on its you know
it's it's plausible and it's scary and
it's and that that to me felt very real
and very visceral
um can we just spawn over Tom Cruise for
us go you go first
[Laughter]
um no I love I love this man I love this
man I love this man and what's so crazy
to me is that he's 61 years old yep and
I was thinking like when I was watching
this movie 61 years old they're
obviously they're filming part two right
now yep
um
and
I don't know Mance if you know but I
know the two big stunts in the next one
and part two oh yes you know the big
stunts in part two I do
the only thing I can think of if I if
you if you're asking me to predict what
a big stunt could be in Dev Reckoning
part two which is I think about halfway
finished filming right now
well in the beginning of part one you
saw the AI at dead reckoning in the
North Pole and it was sunk so how do you
get to that
so somebody's got to get there and it's
in the uh buried uh well uh sunk to the
bottom under the ice in the North Pole
somebody's got to get to that Ai and who
who else but Ethan hunts so how does he
get there he's got to find out where it
is so you're looking at another club
trotting Adventure but the only stunt I
can think of is getting into the sub and
and and all that you know freezing cold
water that's just a guess but if you
have any intel I'm not going to share it
because I'm not allowed but the second
one yeah
We There are shots out released out into
the public so this is not ruining this
for anybody of him out on the wing of an
airplane standing out on the wing of an
airplane he's amazing he's amazing but
people I will just say that the people
who saw that and were like that's cool
that's not the sign wait do you see the
start I haven't seen it but wait do you
hear what it is that's all I'm gonna say
but going back to fawning over Tom
Cruise what I love about him
is that and Haley Atwell said this to me
in when we chatted when he does the Run
he runs with every fiber of his being
his eyelashes are running his fingertips
are running his his everything about him
is running and that is a metaphor for
what he puts into every single
performance because when you see a
mission impossible movie and it's that
excellent I know Christopher Corey is
amazing but it's because Tom Cruise
will never be lazy about one single
background person he will never be
everything is so meticulous
but what I love the most about him as
much as I love him flying off the edge
of a cliff in a motorcycle
no one gives better Faith than Tom
Cruise he's expressed shots he's
expressed like like Ethan Hunt is
obviously a daring character uh you know
complex character with a lot of you know
emotional baggage that we see a little
bit in dead reckoning one but you're
right I think that his his dedication
his commitment his discipline to making
a great movie to making a movie as good
as it can possibly be through thick and
thin again under unprecedented
circumstances and and you could grade
Dev Reckoning on a curve and be like wow
that that movie came out a lot better
than it probably should have under the
circumstances or you could just look at
it as face at face value like I'm doing
and saying it's just it's just amazing
period but it's it's the reason why you
know Fallout when was 2018 you know you
didn't have another Tom Cruise movie
until top gun Maverick which is four
years later that movie was fantastic
definitely a lot of emotion and heart in
that film yeah because of you know going
like the scene with Val Kilmer with
Iceman which was fantastic but now with
the Reckoning won uh there's also a lot
of humor to it like they're they're
self-aware of how Preposterous the IMF
The Impossible missions which actually I
know where you're going with this the
scene during the briefing with Carrie
elwise yeah when he's saying so you just
put something out there and hope that
somebody gets it and takes care of the
job I mean I'm paraphrased yeah yeah but
that's what it is yeah and it works yeah
I was gonna say too like and I'm going
back to Fallout but the scene in Fallout
where he sees Monahan and he's on the
bed
and he wakes up
for anybody who doesn't know what I'm
talking about go back and just put that
moment on he has a moment where he
doesn't move his face yet like he's not
fully conscious but he sees her and all
the feelings before he puts the oh I
can't be with her anymore she's married
to somebody else this where he's excited
to see her and then he catches himself
and realizes the real words World
circumstances just that moment alone on
his face
the fact that this man does not have an
Academy Award stop it right now I'm so
good but also like there's again going
back to the train scene at the end of
dead reckoning one when when uh Ethan
Hunt is holding on to the bar and using
his other hand holding on to Haley
Atwell and there's actually a photo
still that like an official production
photo during the filming of that scene
where you see Ethan Hunt holding on and
the look on his face like he's he's
holding on for dear life you know you're
not watching a character I mean he may
be indestructible to people watching the
film but then you look at the character
and go oh he's scared yeah you believe
you believe in him you think okay scared
and he's vulnerable and you're seen
what's so smart about this because it
never does the thing where the the
heroes like I got this and every he
always is vulnerable and he's always
reluctant and he always puts his team
first those are the three ingredients
that make you so invested in him
emotionally but again that's because Tom
Cruise understands story and yes and
it's weird because we're about to get
into it with first I'm I want to talk
about the new characters in this film
and then the death of Rebecca Ferguson's
character before we get into ranking but
I forgot my thought what was my
thoughts well honestly Haley Atwell who
she's been in so many things I mean
she's been in a Marvel movie she had her
own TV series in Agent Carter and like
this is her moment this is a long long
overdue because I think that she's a
terrific actor and she's great with with
Tom Cruise I like when you have a female
foil for Ethan Hunt well you know no you
don't know what side she is on I think
that for a little while that's kind of
the case with Haley atwell's character
in dead reckon it could even be moving
forward
and it could be moving forward I'm going
to take that as a hint but no I don't
know
no no I don't know what's happening with
the story but I think that that could
happen she's very ambitious right and
she may be on one side right now but
she's incredibly smart and ambitious and
conniving and somebody said she's the
female Ethan Hunt
okay yeah I mean also I think you know
looking back to Rogue nation which is
the first movie where you were
introduced to Elsa Faust played by the
amazing Rebecca Ferguson she's not just
a a female sort of like match she's a
femme fatale and you do not know what
side she is on because one minute she's
saving his butt next minute she's like
off doing her own thing she's excellent
in Rogue Nation the scene in the Vienna
opera house I mean it's not uh well
we'll get to that but uh but I thought
Haley Atwell at this stage of the
mission films to bring in a new face and
have it be like like to for her to rise
to the occasion yeah for such a
demanding film and such a larger than
life screen presence she she crushed it
and she held her own and she knocked it
out of the park okay I'm gonna be honest
I didn't like her character at first I
didn't either at first but I grew to
like her and that's why I didn't like
her at first because I'm like don't you
dare mess with my Ethan don't you
message me and I'm not saying like a
giggling school girl like I am a little
bit but I was like he's the hero like I
don't like that you keep and you're not
listening to him and he keeps trying to
help you and you're not listening and
she's just a pain in the ass
Ethan knows what he's doing but then I
realize she gets under your skin because
she's that good an actress because she's
so formidable in such a presence if
somebody's pissing you off that much
they're doing their job because that's
that was her job in the beginning of the
film and she did win me over and she's
she's unbelievable and she's a wonderful
person to talk to as well and she's
absolutely by the way she walked in to
the interview room and I was like these
are glasses I was like who's the
supermodel she took her glass I'm like
oh that's Haley she's stunning she's
like five foot ten she's a goddess but
anyway
um okay so what did you think about then
ilsophile's demise see I have a theory
the brainer back in part two well did we
see her die well he saw her die unless
she what I mean maybe she wasn't I mean
I don't know that's a really good
question but that people are upset about
that death
She's a great character Rebecca Ferguson
to come into the fifth Mission
Impossible film which opened in July of
2015. again this is the fifth movie in
the series and and up to that point a
lot of people felt like that was the
best in the series and at the time it
was uh it's still my second favorite
overall but I'll get to that but she was
so great because you missed chi chi
again held her own and and just this
this one scene that you know people talk
about the stunts and there's a lot of
great stunt pieces in Rogue Nation it
was really hard to pick one and I'll
tell you which one I picked but the
scene at the Vienna opera house when
someone's out to assassinate the the
Prime Minister and like you know all
that stuff that's going on in the
rafters and everything while the Opera
is going on and like Tom Cruise is
fighting someone is twice the size and
and when Elsa Faust wearing that
beautiful yellow dress picks up the the
gun and and aims it it's like something
out of a Hitchcock movie it was
excellent and she was so good so when
she died yes I was surprised sad to see
her go I mean she's doing she's a very
into Man actor she's got her show Silo
on Apple which is very very good she's
also producing that you know maybe she
just wanted to have a graceful it's
possible she did but I
um but she i p I think people were upset
because they feel they felt like it
didn't she wasn't mourned enough it was
mid-movie it wasn't the dramatic
conclusion at the end of the movie and I
think a lot of people thought of Tom
Cruise ever decided not to do Mission
Impossible she could take over the
mantle I've heard people say that about
her I I mean it's Tom or nothing yeah I
feel the same way yeah like good luck
yeah that's not gonna happen all right
on our watch do we have time to do all
of our I think we'll just go through
yeah let's go through okay you go first
number seven on your list oh man see
Nancy Nancy my number seven is the first
mission impossible okay my number seven
is the second mission Apostle and keep
in mind keep in mind ladies and
gentlemen and everyone watching at home
is that I truly do love all I do two
movies so if a movie is number six or
seven on my list I still love it to
Pieces yeah so why is number I'm just
curious why is number one your last be
because it felt more like just a
traditional National sign movie I think
just the this I I don't I think the
series went to another level when
Christopher McCrory took over so all of
Chris mcquaries are my top three yep it
went to another octane he is a rock star
of a director
um and I think the stunts I think it
evolved I think the story evolved it's
also was shot so long ago I mean so much
has evolved it's a little bit dated when
you go back and watch it so and it was
just getting going so that was that's my
number six if I still love it well well
okay so mission impossible one is my
number six and Brian De Palma directed
the film it came out in May of 1996 and
then seven months later Jerry Maguire
opened so 96 was a very very good year
for Tom Cruise but but the stunts are
great you know the scene in Langley when
he's hanging on the wire breaking into
the the safe area and then of course the
last scene in the tunnel on the train is
amazing Mission Impossible 2 is my
seventh not because I don't like it just
because it's it's a little I guess
I love how stylized director John Wu
made the film but by that point in John
Woo's career with films like like face
off and hard-boiled his signature style
you know with the fire and the guns
firing through there and the doves got
to be a little bit of a cliche for him
yeah uh but I still think it is an
extremely entertaining film in the
action's awesome well a lot of people
have that mi2 as their number seven I
think that's sort of the consensus that
it's the weakest one it is not even
my number six oh what is your number six
mi3 is my number six okay
um again we're getting into territory
where I love them all I and I love that
that's where Michelle moynihan's
character was introduced the love the
love of his life I do love that aspect
of it I Love Philip Seymour Hoffman I
wasn't a huge fan of the Maggie Q
character wasn't a huge fan of Carrie
Russell's performance in that movie I
didn't it was fine but I didn't
I'm very attached to certain characters
and certain female characters and as we
go up the list you'll understand that
the reason why mi2 is not at the bottom
of my list is because of the female lead
that I thought was the best female lead
we've had in the series yeah so I I
would say three is my number six okay so
three is my number five okay so this is
JJ Abrams his first movie directed and I
remember I think of all the missions
it's the one that I've seen the least
even though it's not the one that I like
the least but I think I've only seen it
like twice and I remember like yes I was
doing my list for this episode of of the
after show Rotten Tomatoes starring
Nikki Novak thinking like it's JJ's
first movie as a director he's directed
a lot of TV of course he's produced a
lot of TV and even though Tom Cruise is
in the film you know you have uh
obviously Carrie Russell in the movie
who JJ worked with on on Felicity and
the movie itself felt like alias
which Jennifer Garner show uh and I'm
not saying like it felt like a TV series
it very much felt like a movie but it
was the inspiration of the TV stuff that
he did was very much prevalent yeah but
I loved the relationship obviously that
you get to see you know Ethan Hunt
trying to you know do the family thing
with Michelle Moynihan and they're great
together yeah I'd like the film very
very much and again Philip Seymour
Hopman is great he really is great
um so my number five would be number two
Mission Impossible number two although
it was tough because Thandie Newton is
still even with Mission Impossible dead
reckoning part one my favorite female
character of all time of the franchise
and weirdly I have read that she didn't
have a great experience yeah on a film
right but I'm so sorry the chemistry
between the two of them I think it was
the most sexy time we ever saw Tom have
in a Mission Impossible film that's
first hanging from the cliff yeah like
it was sexy that relationship it wasn't
the Michelle love of his life there was
like a tension between the two of them
and maybe it was because of the real
life tension I don't know yeah but it
was
it was like there was something about it
it was just you felt on the and he was
electrified which is when he looked at
it he was electrified so the two of them
together made up for some other things
in the film that didn't work for me okay
what number are we on number four my
number four through one could completely
be interchangeable given any time of the
day any day that I'm talking about these
next four movies they are all great they
could all be made the argument could be
made that any one of these next four
films is the best mission of them all
and in and they are all they they are
the best in different ways but Ghost
Protocol was is my not not only my
number four again I freaking love this
movie yeah I love this movie uh it it it
brings Mission Impossible back to the
basics of the TV series that ran from
1966 to 1973 where it was an impossible
missions force it was a group of
characters it wasn't just the Ethan Hunt
show and like you really felt the
camaraderie the the teamwork they all
had different skills that they brought
to the fore and uh there was a lot more
humor it was more self-aware like let's
have fun with this let's make maybe
these gadgets don't work right and like
you know at the beginning of the movie
when he gets the message and his oh this
message will self-destruct in five
seconds and he's walking away from the
phone booth and it's like not
self-destructing he goes back and he
like bangs on it you know like that's
what like I see what they're doing here
and I love that yeah well I'm the same
my my number four is Ghost Protocol so
there we go what's your number three
oh Rogue nation is my number three why
well like I said macquarie's the man the
myth and the legend and he's his three
films that he has done are my three
favorite and I had to pick a third
and the other two are my clearly my two
favorite but I did love Rogue Nation
okay Rogue nation is my number two oh my
number three is Fallout again could flip
you asked me this question again in
three hours I know this could flip I
know but look I love faux out Fallout is
awesome I mean every cattle's character
was a great addition uh the fight in the
bathroom was excellent
um and yeah the jumping scene in the air
that was amazing but the reason I give
Rogue Nation The Edge and this is
macquarie's first first time directing a
mission film even though he had done
some some script work on Ghost Protocol
I don't think he got credit for it but
you know he wrote the screenplay and he
directed the film and I feel like the
plotting the actual plotting of Rogue
nation is a little bit more intricate
like yeah it's a great action but you've
got to pay attention to the story
because the story is very well written
it's smart and and there's a lot of
details you just gotta pay attention to
it so and again and you've got a lot of
great scenes like obviously the plane
the cargo plane scene the scene at the
Vienna Opera House the motorcycle chase
you know the uh uh the underwater scene
like there's a lot of great stuff in
Rogue Nations it's so hard to choose
okay what's your number two my number
two is dead reckoning part one okay okay
I
bias I just saw it so it's so easy to
say it's my favorite and it and there
are elements of it that are my favorite
because I do think everyone does improve
on the last
but overall the reason why I gave
Fallout The Edge is because
the air the helicopter sequence in
Fallout was insane
was insane and I didn't include that in
favorite sons of Toms but that whole
sequence and the way it was shot and the
the when the the pl the helicopter keeps
is stuck and keeps falling down and then
when he falls off the helicopter and
lands on that round
it's so good but there's one moment
that made me put it number one which was
the blackout moment when it fades to
Black when he's climbing up at the very
end oh comes climbing and they decide to
just go quiet
and it goes to Black it's like The
Sopranos which was the greatest TV
amending of all yeah so it tells you how
what how much I like Ambi ambiguity but
it it you just you don't know what's
going to happen it's the choice to put
that moment in the film
and then you see him at the top and he
lays back and by the way when he lays
back why did you lay less so close to
the end got a few fiends before you
decide to take a break but that to me
put me over the edge and that that's why
I would choose Fallout I think overall
when I I know what you're saying about
story yeah but overall set pieces the
way it's strung together the way a film
doesn't let up the brawl in the bathroom
like all of it as a whole as a cohesive
hole is my favorite film I listen you
are right to pick Fallout as your number
one I think there is a consensus among
most people that Fallout is the best
what I what I posted on uh social media
shortly after uh Dev Reckoning opening
was like okay here's my ranking which is
the ranking I'm giving you that hasn't
changed what's yours and a lot of people
are putting fall as our number one but
like you pointed out Nikki correctly
because you know dead reckoning is new
and I just saw it three times in like
less than two weeks for now it is my
number one Mission movie I just think
again the plotting the story all that
stuff matters obviously that matters and
here's a film about AI I defy AI to
write a screenplay as proficient as
Chris Macquarie has written these last
mission movies they're great and yes the
villain the AI the reveal about the
entity and all that it took me like it
was a meta moment if you will where I
went this is exactly the right movie at
the right time because exactly what
everyone is going on about now this
movie is saying it could get much much
much much much worse
so it is for that reason alone but also
you know like you I mean I know a lot
about the making of the film and
everything that went into it I mean it's
been very very well publicized that it
was a difficult shoot and look at the
results they made a great movie so by
maybe just that background knowledge of
that is making me go this movie is far
better than than I expected it to be
than it probably deserved to be and that
they made a top-notch film under the
worst of circumstances and it was a
grand slam home run so as we wrap up
let's let's talk do you think this is
the greatest action franchise of all
time yes I do yeah there's not a bad
movie in the bunch I know people oh
Mission Impossible 2 wasn't that great I
don't care I love it I love them all I
there's something to enjoy the hell out
of each and every one of them and again
pretty much if you follow the
progression of the films released they
do keep topping themselves and to be 30
30 almost 30 years into a franchise to
be able to do that like unfortunately
the Indiana Jones franchise has not been
able to lay that claim the Star Wars
movies have not been able to lay that
claim John Wick the the John Wick is a
series that absolutely does lay that
claim because the first three movies
were great four wasn't as good as three
but it was better than two but the John
Wick movies are more action films you
know yeah and I love the child with
movies and John Wick 4 was fantastic and
I hope they make a fifth but they are
more more fighting more martial arts
type of movies I mean you got the car
chases something in there too but the
production the set pieces in the Mission
Impossible movies are far more complex
and intricate that's why it's the better
action I don't I don't actually don't
even think it's close I don't even think
it's close I don't think there's an
action franchise like you said over time
that seven movies later
keep improving on themselves and
improving themselves amazing um my last
question to you Nancy where do you want
it to go in part two and do you want
time to continue afterwards well okay so
what I want what I wanted to make a
point about part one is that even though
it's right there in the title dead
reckoning part one it does not feel like
a part one it feels like a complete
movie you are left feeling very
satisfied beginning middle and end it
doesn't leave you hanging like across
the spider verse the way it ended like a
comic book to be continued I mean yeah
that's cool and everything but there's
no ending so I was a little kind of
unsatisfied that I didn't like like I
mean I look I love spider verse I love
all those movies but that Reckoning one
felt complete where it is so complete
that even though we see the sub sync at
the beginning of the film and that's
that Reckoning and that is where the AI
is I don't know where the hell it's
going to go regardless I do not want
part two when it comes out either in 24
or maybe 25 depending on how long the
strike the actor strike goes on because
it is going to affect shooting
I want Tom Cruise to keep going Tom and
Chris together to keep going with these
Mission movies because if they can keep
topping themselves I want to see them
keep topping themselves I really
actually really love that because so
many people are like oh you should stop
it's enough already yeah
why why I wanted to he doesn't want to
stop clearly
we don't want him to stop
uh yeah I don't I actually think my only
criticism of the film would be that they
didn't need a part one in the title
because I think it was a complete movie
and I guess all every movie has sort of
felt very contained and hasn't felt like
a continuation but you could have there
is a little bit of a tiny little bit of
a cliffhanger-ish kind of tease again
that's a very very you could have had
that without even writing in the part
one but my my hope is there's a very
very clear reason why it's called part
one and that is because part two is
Gonna Knock our socks off where they
take it and actually that's what
Macquarie did say to me he's like if you
think this was intense and insane and
amazing you just you have no idea what
we have planned and that's why I think
overall as an arc my I just hope they
Rock our world I mean in part two I just
like talking to you now you saying that
just makes me go how on Earth
especially with these last four movies
how the hell are they going to top
themselves but at the same time Nikki I
absolutely think that they will I think
they will too I believe it they're not
going to make the part one the better of
the two they've got to make part two the
better of the two you gotta gotta you
gotta go to the next level It's gotta be
like The Empire Strikes Back of mission
impossible it has to be yeah that's why
you call it part one and part two
because you know what's coming oh my God
because your T that part the words part
one in the title is a tease I want it
now I want it now the carrot dangling
now the cube we want it now but by the
way he did tell me and we sort of broke
some news here at Rotten Tomatoes it is
not going to be the last one the next
one that they have ideas good good
that's good news
it's the same you know I mean but you
know obviously
that commitment knowing that that's him
I mean some people go like why does he
do that it's really dangerous but that's
the commitment and the dedication and
the the discipline to making the best
possible in theater big screen movie
going experience uh you know when all
the uh we were coming out of the of the
pandemic and Tom Cruise was promoting
Maverick uh you know he said well what
why don't you just release it on like
streaming and he says I make movies for
the big screen and I'm like you go uh
and I will I will be sitting in theater
watching those and when every single
thing was going to streaming to know
what you have and to hold on to it they
held Paramount too yeah those are his
nerves again his nerves of Steel where
he doesn't get phased he doesn't get
bothered and he's so disciplined that he
knew I'm just gonna sit on this because
I know what we got and look what
happened look at the summer that we're
having at the box office there's so many
great movies can you imagine in a
meeting you know in the like the you
know whatever production or you know
Studio person says you know I'm not sure
when we're going to be able to release
this in theaters maybe we should put
this on a streaming service can you just
imagine Tom Cruise going
there's no way that's going to happen
like that's like a mission impossible
there's no way that's going to happen I
mean and and again there's something to
be said about that commitment in the
face of just unprecedented uh
circumstances to Prevail and persevere
and the payoff is that not only did they
release a great movie in theaters but
everyone is enjoying it and people are
enjoying like that really was the
kickstart
to people going back to the theater
absolutely and this Renaissance that
people had you know and now people are
loving going back to the theater and you
don't hear the word streaming going but
I like to stream it you don't hear that
as much like people are really enjoying
it makes me so happy when people go and
they call me and they tell me they love
to move here whatever Mance Nikki you're
the best you are the best tell me tell
me tell everybody where they can find
you just where to find you follow me on
Twitter and Instagram and now threads at
movie mans that's where I live it it's
it's
impossible to have a better guest than
you you rock Nikki you rock yes thank
you for joining and thank you all for
joining us for this episode of the after
show we hope you had a blast with us
I would love to know your ranking I want
to know what your ranking is but we will
see you on the next episode and thanks
again for joining for this very epic
Monumental movie Mission Impossible dead
reckoning part one bye see you next time